si les voyages dans l'espace de vienne
sur et financièrement abordable il
risque de faire des émules et de devenir
un vaste marché et dans ce cas mars
attirera sûrement d'innombrables
touristes quant aux voyageurs moins
fortunés c'est vers la lune qu'ils
s'envoleront mais les destinations
vraiment exotiques seront bien plus
lointaines
les souvenirs de vacances des voyageurs
de demain évoquons peut-être titan euros
you et pluton les planètes des confins
du système solaire et leurs lunes
elle se trouve à des milliards de km de
la terre compte tenu de la technologie
actuelle envoyer des engins spatiaux
aussi loin constitue un véritable défi
mais les scientifiques sont prêts à le
relever leurs sondes nous montre déjà
toute une variété de paysages façonnés
et colorée par des marées des volcans et
d'autres phénomènes pour lesquels nous
n'avons même pas encore de nom
c'est petit monde glacé du système
solaire recèle d'innombrables énigmes
qui attendent simplement que nous les
élus si dion
ce sont véritablement des mondes à part
ces planètes se trouve dans les confins
du système solaire bien plus grosse que
la terre les géantes gazeuses sont très
éloignées de nous
jupiter la plus grande à tellement été
étudiés qu'on a tendance à oublier
qu'elle est à plus de 600 millions de
kilomètres
les saturn est presque à un milliard
trois cents millions de kilomètres ça
n'est pas la porte à côté pour un petit
robot terrestre quand voyageurs de est
passé à côté d'uranus en 1986 elle était
déjà dans l'espace depuis neuf ans et le
rendez vous attendu depuis si longtemps
n'a duré que quelques heures
cette planète n'a pour ainsi dire aucune
atmosphère et sa surface était invisible
quand la sonde atteint neptune trois ans
plus tard ces instruments de mesure
menacé de finir congelés la faible
lumière solaire rendait toute
photographie difficile mais la sonde a
tout de même exécuté la majeure partie
de son travail et a envoyé des données
qu'on étudie toujours aujourd'hui
les scientifiques veulent retourner aux
confins du système solaire une sonde est
en route vers saturne et une autre
partir en direction des lunes de jupiter
d'ici quelque temps une troisième ira
peut-être vers pluton
les astronomes ont conscience que ces
missions dureront plusieurs dizaines
d'années et qu'elles ne seront pas sans
risque
alors pourquoi les entreprendre parce
que c'est une nouvelle frontière parce
que c'est le far west des sciences
planétaires c'est le pays des merveilles
d'une physique très particulière nous ne
savons pas grand chose il ya beaucoup de
place pour l'imagination la créativité
et l'exploration temps l'intellectuel
que physique
en envoyant des engins spatiaux dans des
endroits où on n'est jamais allé
c'est un peu surréaliste mais le système
solaire c'est chez nous et on le connaît
très bien les bordures du système
solaire sont bien plus prometteuse pour
ceux d'entre nous qui ont envie de se
lancer dans l'exploration
cette exploration met principalement
l'accent sur les l'une des planètes
lointaines
plus nous les connaissons plus nous
découvrons que ces postes avancés fait
de glace sont des mondes fascinants
autour de neptune se trouve une grosse
lune
baptisée triton d'énormes geyser crash
des panaches d'azoté liquide
incroyablement froid le plus gros
satellite de saturne titan est aussi
imposant qu'une planète les dispose
d'une atmosphère nuageuse plus épaisse
que celle de la terre
you qui gravitent autour de jupiter
dégage du soufre brûlant par
l'intermédiaire de dizaines de volcan
géant europe
une autre lune de jupiter semble
dissimuler un océan qui la recouvre
entièrement sous une épaisse couche de
glace
si ce petit monde contient de l'eau à
l'état liquide abrite illégalement la
vie le plus phénoménal europe et c'est
qu'on s'est fait à l'idée qu'il y à une
zone d'existence pour les biosphère
autour des étoiles
en clair une planètes comme la terre
doit être à une certaine distance du
soleil pour avoir de l'eau à l'état
liquide à sa surface europe bousculent
cette théorie car elle se situe 5 fois
plus loin du soleil que nous mais elle
dispose peut-être d'un océan d'eau
liquide depuis sa naissance soit quatre
milliards et demi d'années on devrait
avoir je crois que c'est ce qui va se
passer
un programme d'exploration qui
rivalisera avec celui de mars
et s'il ya un 2e 6 ans dans le système
mais notre histoire commence bien loin
des géantes gazeuses et de leur lune
depuis le début des années 90 les
astronomes ont confirmé l'existence
d'une zone jusqu alors jamais repéré à
l'intérieur du système solaire elle
étend son immensité au delà de pluton et
pourrait bien contenir d'autres mondes
identique à cette planète
ce congélateur sombre la ceinture de
kuiper tient son nom de gerald peter
piper un astronome américano hollandais
qui a déduit théoriquement son existence
dans les années 50 il était réputé pour
ses recherches portant sur un certain
type de comètes
après avoir mesuré lors bits de ces
corps il a découvert un indice sur leur
provenance
son idée était que des comètes circulent
dans le système solaire
elles ont des périodes de 20 ou de cinq
angles et on les appelle des comètes à
courte période et elle se déplace dans
le plan du système solaire elle tourne
autour du soleil comme des planètes
expliquer pourquoi elles ont de tels
orbite est très difficile à moins qu'un
objet qui se trouve dans le système
solaire soit un berceau de comètes et
que nous puissions pas le voir kuipers
et dont 10 il doit se trouver aux
confins du système solaire
cette hypothèse a été vérifiée dans les
années 90 avec la découverte d'une
nouvelle catégorie d'icebergs céleste
ils ressemblent à des points sur les
photos prises avec un long temps de pose
par les télescopes géants mais sur une
période de plusieurs jours ou de
plusieurs semaines on constate qu'ils
bougent trahissant ainsi leur
appartenance à la ceinture de kuyper
situé bien au delà de neptune ce qu'on
trouve là bas est le matériau le plus
naturel le plus native de la nébuleuse
d'où vient le soleil si on va voir à
quoi il ressemble on en saura plus sur
la nébuleuse dont il est originaire à
moins de comprendre le système solaire
on ne comprendra jamais comment jupiter
neptune uranus et saturn sont apparus
ces minuscules corps des confins du
système solaire donne des indices pour
découvrir comment les gros se sont
formés la plupart de ces objets sont
effectivement très petit à l'échelle de
l'astronomie les premiers découvert ont
été des boules de glace d'une dizaines
voire d'une centaine de kilomètres de
diamètre
depuis la fin du xxème siècle les
astronomes piste cependant des objets
d'un millier de km de large soit la
moitié de plus tant d'autres mondes
encore plus gros attendent-ils d'être
découvert une autre planète x roe de tel
dans les ténèbres qui noie les confins
du système solaire
l'idée d'une planète x est intéressante
savoir si nous avons terminé le
recensement des grandes planètes du
système solaire est une question
vraiment passionnante
il n'y a aucune preuve dans les
mouvements des grandes planètes qui
indique qu il en manque une
cependant il se peut qu'il existe une
planète très éloignée du soleil environ
trois fois plus loin que neptune qui
face à peu près la taille de mars
or une telle planète n'aurait aucune
incidence sur l'orbité de neptune
il est donc possible que très loin
d'autres objets attendent qu'on les
découvre la ceinture de kuiper a déjà
quelque chose à nous montrer ses plus
gros objets sont aussi les plus petites
planètes du système solaire
à commencer par pluton en fait elle est
de loin la plus petite
pluton paix de taille si réduite que les
astronomes se demande même si on peut la
classer parmi les planètes
depuis quelques années son statut prête
à controverse
devons-nous oui ou non la considérer
comme une planète
elle est la plus petite du système
solaire quatre des planètes disposent de
l'une plus grosse que pluton qui plus
est elle a une orbite excentrique qui
s'apparente à certaines de celles
rencontrées dans la ceinture de kuiper
pour toutes ces raisons un nombre
grandissant d'astronomes préfère la
considérer comme un objets
transneptuniens de grande taille
d'autres ne sont pas d'accord avenue ans
qu'un monde sphérique de 2300 km de
diamètre qui tourne autour du soleil sur
une orbite est une planète
un point c'est tout
tout le monde s'accordent cependant à
dire que la neuvième planète est trop
petit et trop éloignée de nous pour
qu'on obtienne une image précise pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années
pluton à ressembler à n'importe quel
point lumineux au télescope
puis elle est apparue sous la forme de
deux points en 1978 un astronome du
naval observatory américain a découvert
la lune de pluton charon moitié moins
grosse que pluton elle tourne à
seulement dix neuf mille kilomètres
autour de cette dernière
certains astronomes considère donc ce
petit duo comme une planète double sur
des images prises récemment par le
télescope hubble
charon apparaît un peu plus sombre que
pluton la composition de la surface de
chaque monde semble être légèrement
différente ce qui paraît difficile à
expliquer vu leur proximité
à l'aide du télescope spatial
les astronomes ont commencé à dresser un
plan grossier de plus tant ces taches
claires et sombres indique qu'elle a des
caractéristiques de surface intéressante
juste à la limite de la résolution de
hubble les zones claires sont très
réfléchissante comme de la neige
neige se compose la zot une matière que
nous respirons c'est azox sublime sous
la faible lumière solaire pour générer
une atmosphère ténu mais très étendue
autour de plus tôt la pression est assez
basse environ un millième de celle qui
existe dans cette pièce c'est pour en
apprendre plus sur cette fragile
atmosphère que les astronomes ont très
envie d'envoyer ne sont sûrs plus tant
elle visitera pluton et charron puis il
ira observer certains objets de la
ceinture de kuiper mais pour la plus
grande frustration des astronomes
les projets de survol de pluton sont
depuis des années remis à plus tard
techniquement c'est une mission assez
sain ceux qui s'intéressent à
l'exploration de pluton ont découvert
qu'il a fallu une bonne dizaine d'années
pour faire sortir cette mission des
dédales administratifs de washington et
la mettre sur pied car le temps presse
pluton dérive sur une orbite elliptique
et est passée au plus près du soleil en
1989 en ce moment elle s'en éloigne elle
ne sera pas aussi chaudes avant deux
cent cinquante ans
son atmosphère qui se réchauffe et
s'étire sous la chaleur du soleil sera
de nouveau gelés d'ici 2010 environ les
astronomes veulent observer pluton avant
que son atmosphère se congèle et forme
une fine couche de neige d'azoté mais
quelque chose d'autre divise les experts
pour lancer au plus tôt une mission la
kz2 pluton s'incline tellement que la
planète est presque couché sur le flanc
en ce moment même presque toute la
surface passe du jour à la nuit tous les
six jours et demi le temps qu'il faut à
pluton pour effectuer une révolution
autour de son axe tandis que pluton se
déplace sur son orbite son axe polaire
fx dans l'espace et le soleil éclaire de
plus en plus un seul hémisphère l'autre
passe donc dans une nuit polaire et à
chaque année qui s'écoule tous nous
perdons plusieurs centaines de milliers
de kilomètres carrés et cette obscurité
ne libérera pas ce terrain pour 60 ans
si les astronomes se passionne autant
pour pluton c'est qu'ils pensent avoir
trouvé sa jumelle plus près du soleil ce
sosie potentiel s'appelle triton et
c'est le plus gros satellite de neptune
triton qui fait les trois quarts de la
taille de notre lune est un endroit très
étrange une hypothèse de spectaculaires
prétend que triton était autrefois un
monde en soi qui a été chassé de la
ceinture de kuiper puis capturé par
l'attraction gravitationnelle de neptune
en raison de son angle d'approché
ce globe s'est mis à tourner autour de
neptune à l'envers
triton est unique en son genre parmi les
grandes lignes du système solaire car
elle tourne autour de sa planète dans un
sens opposé à la rotation de celle-ci et
neptune ne cessent de freiner son
satellite
ce mouvement rétrograde n'est pas stable
et leurs beats de triton doucement mais
sûrement se réduit
les calculs indiquent que d'ici quelques
milliards d'années seulement
triton s'écrasera sur neptune
situé à plus de 4 milliards de
kilomètres du soleil
triton à une température supérieure de
seulement 40 degrés au zéro absolu sur
triton la glace est aussi dur que de la
roche
mais curieusement cette lune n'est pas
complètement gelé à l'intérieur
quand voyageurs de est passé à proximité
de neptune en 1989 elle a constaté que
triton était entouré par une faible
atmosphère d'azoté alimenté par des
volcans froid des geysers nous voyons
ici des geysers qui crachait de la
matière à 8 km au dessus de la surface
maintien et ensuite emprisonné dans une
atmosphère très basse densité et dérivés
dans le sens du vent sur plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres nous avons
observé cela sur traitants et sur les
images nous avons fait les cicatrices
provoquées par ces geysers des sillons
sombre laisser à la surface il ne
restait donc pas que de la zone mais
aussi une substance noire
ce phénomène demeure un grand mystère
qui n'a pas été encore vraiment résolu
dans certaines conditions la zot peut se
congeler et devenir aussi clair que du
verre sur triton il fonctionne peut-être
comme le verre d'une serre une des
explications pourrait être que la faible
lumière solaire effleurant le satellite
soit prisonnière de la surface gelée la
chaleur ferait fondre une partie de la
zone qui remonterait alors vers la
surface et surgirait sous forme de
geysers passant de l'état liquide à
l'état gazeux
cet azote alimenterait ainsi la mince
atmosphère de triton
quelle que soit l'explication le paysage
de triton semble remarquablement intacte
les images de voyageurs de n'indique que
quelques cratère c'est curieux car
d'après les astronomes triton a été
percutée sans arrêt par des objets
dérivant en provenance de la ceinture de
kuyper qui est juste à côté du moins à
l'échelle de l'astronomie
pourtant voyageurs donne à repérer
presque aucune trace d'impact
le fait que triton soit porteur d'eau si
peu de cratères signifie que sa surface
est très jeune de l'ordre de 52 à 100
millions d'années c'est à dire un
instant par rapport à l'âge du système
solaire cela indique que sa surface a
été actif sur le plan géologique à très
grande échelle une échelle bien plus
grande que les simples geyser pendant au
moins 98 ou 99 % de l'existence du
système solaire briton nous enseigne à
nouveau la leçon essentielle de
l'exploration planétaire
partout nous envoyons pour la première
fois un engin spatial
nous sommes abasourdis par la richesse
et la variété de la nature cette leçon
nous allons bientôt la réviser une sonde
parti vers saturne va bientôt étudié une
lune enfermé dans une danse atmosphère
d'azoté sous ce voile de brume se cache
un panorama qu aucun argument n'a jamais
contemplé certains pensent que la
surface est balayée par dés pluies de
méthane liquide et qu'on y trouve des
lacs de gaz naturel à l'état liquide
cela relève t-il simplement du fantasme
ou la vérité sera t-elle encore plus
surprenantes les scientifiques le
découvrirons bientôt
inclinait selon un angle curieux sainte
de bandeaux de nuages couleurs pastel
est entouré par ses délits casano
saturne est un bonheur en trois
dimensions vue au télescope la merveille
aux anneaux est devenu un des symboles
de l'astronomie
elle accueille une famille d'une
trentaine de satellites dont la plupart
sont beaucoup plus petits que notre lune
en 1980-81 la sonde voyageurs 2 est
passé non loin de ses lunes et a
constaté qu'elle était dépourvu d'air
criblé de cratères et gelé sauf une cet
unique exception ces titans city temps
ne tournait pas autour de saturne mais
du soleil on l'appellerait sûrement une
planète
il est plus grand que mercure moins que
mars il a une atmosphère plus dense que
celle de la terre la pression sur titan
est celle qui lie au fond d'une piscine
c'est donc une atmosphère très dense
cette atmosphère contient une brume de
haute altitude qui enferme complètement
quittant la surface est demeuré au pack
jusqu'en 1990 date à laquelle d
astronomie ont fait rebondir des ondes
radar la brume et aussi perméable à la
lumière infrarouge ce qui a permis à
hubble de repérer deux vagues marques
similaires à celles observées sur pluton
les astronomes ne sont pas sûrs de
savoir ce que ces marques représentent
si ce n'est que les zones plus clair
pourrait bien être des plateaux de
taille continentale mais c'est
l'atmosphère qui les intrigue le plus
seuls deux mondes dans tout le système
solaire dispose d'une atmosphère épaisse
composé principalement d'azov la terre
et titan la grosse différence entre les
deux en plus de la température
c'est le deuxième gaz le plus abondant
sur terre c'est l'oxygène sur titan
c'est le méthane sous l'influencé de la
lumière solaire
le méthane réagi avec la zot pour créer
un brouillard de molécules organiques
c'est cette brume qui nous masquer la
vue les astronomes supposent que cette
brume se condensent pour former des
gouttelettes qui se dépose à la surface
pour former une bourre organique
même s'il fait moins 200 degrés sur
titan l'air n'est pas assez froid pour
geler les bruines de méthane pourtant
cette pluie constante et ce qui rend les
chercheurs perplexe comment se fait-il
que titan ne finisse pas par en manquait
qu'est ce qui met du méthane dans
l'atmosphère de titan nous l'ignorons
mais il existe deux hypothèses
plausibles
la première c'est qu'il y ait des
volcans actifs en surface qui crachent
du méthane et non du dioxyde de carbone
contrairement à ceux de la terre l'autre
c'est qu'il y ait une espèce d'océan de
méthane et des tannes comme la vapeur
d'eau apparaît dans l'atmosphère
terrestre le réapprovisionnement se
faisant par évaporation des océans
il ya peut-être du méthane dans
l'atmosphère de titan en raison de
l'évaporation de méthane et détaille
certains astronomes considère titans
comme un monde primitif qui n'aurait
guère évoluer la terre et titans ont été
fabriqués à partir de la même génération
de matériaux mais titan n'a jamais été
sorti du congélateur
est ce un monde qui est resté à son état
originel où les réactions chimique de
son atmosphère l'ont ils poussaient a
évolué d'une manière unique en son genre
pour les spécialistes c'est une question
fascinante
a dit ensemble nous donner l'exemple du
type d'atmosphère qui a dû exister sur
terre d'après les scientifiques avant
l'apparition de la vie nous pouvons donc
étudié des éléments organiques sur titan
nous avons la chance de pouvoir examiner
la chimie qui s'exerce sur ces éléments
et qui a peut-être donné naissance à la
vie sur terre
on ne peut plus le faire sur notre
planète car il n'existe plus de matières
organiques libre la présence de
l'oxygène les ayant détruit on peut le
faire sur titan mais pas dans un cadre
naturel sur terre l'expérience de titan
est sur le point d'avoir lieu une sonde
nommé cassini est en route vers saturne
elle va se mettre en orbite au milieu de
l'année 2004 et s'intéresser tout
particulièrement à titan une de ses
premières tâches consistera à
photographier titan avec des filtres
spéciaux pour dresser une carte de son
relief en tant que responsable de
l'imagerie haute résolution effectué par
cassini
je m'intéresse tout particulièrement à
la surface nous n'avons pas encore vu
car les caméras de voyageurs 2 ne
pouvait pas le faire
le système de cassini lui peut y
parvenir
et avec un peu de chance il y arrivera
comme nous n'avons jamais vu la surface
de titan on ne peut que conjecturer sur
ce qui s'y trouve
il nous a fallu 23 ans pour envoyer
cassini vers saturne et ses caméras
pourront observer les reliefs de tous
ces satellites y compris titan avec une
résolution d'une dizaine de mètres
quelques mois après sa mise en orbite
autour de saturne cassini enverra sur
titan une capsule baptisée huyghens elle
tient son nom de l'astronome qui a
découvert le satellite elle descendra en
parachute dans l'atmosphère opaque en
mesurant la température et la pression
la capsule tentera ensuite de procéder
aux premiers atterrissages sur la lune
d'une autre planète se posera tel sur un
sol solide ou plongera tel dans un
bassin de gaz naturel liquide
j'ai hâte de voir si wigan atterrira
avec un bruit sourd ou un bruit
d'éclaboussures personne ne le sait nous
savons qu'il existe sur titan des
endroits élevés et brillant on les voit
de la terre nous savons qu'il devrait y
avoir en théorie des dépôts
d'hydrocarbures de l'éthane
principalement liquéfié à de très basses
températures
s'agit-il de marais et par-delà coup de
grand'mère on ne peut pas le dire avec
certitude
tout un monde va nous être révélé pour
la première fois ce sera un des moments
les plus spectaculaires de l'histoire de
l'exploration du système solaire
on verra peut-être des volcans actifs
rachetés du méthane dans l'atmosphère ou
un océan de méthane et des tannes ou des
rivières
il y aura peut-être un cycle
météorologiques le méthane remplaçant
l'eau nous l'ignorons mais nous le
saurons d'ici quelques années et ce sera
vraiment passionnant
quelques années après l'exploration de
titan un autre engin s'envolera vers les
confins du système solaire
ce sera la première sonde terrestre à se
placer en orbite autour de la lune une
planète autre que la terre sa mission
cherchez un océan d'eau si elle est
couronnée de succès cette mission
représentera peut-être notre premier
grand pas vers la découverte d'une vie
extra terrestre
il n'existe aucune planète comparable à
jupiter longtemps la cible préférée des
astronomes elle un volume plus de 1000
fois supérieur à celui de la terre aucun
astronaute ni posera jamais le pied car
c'est une planète gazeuse
il n'y a pas de surface les astronautes
de demain devront donc se poser sur une
de ses lunes il n'y en a 16 connu
actuellement dont quatre lunes géantes
découvertes par galilée en 116 110
dans le film 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
un vaisseau terriens s'aventure parmi
ces satellites réalisé au milieu des
années 60
le film décrit les satellites galiléens
comme quatre boules de neige géante
presque identique
c'était le meilleur pronostic qu'on
pouvait mettre à l'époque la réalité
dépassant la fiction
c'est en 2001 qu'une sonde terrestre
s'est mise en orbite autour de jupiter
comme le vaisseau du film une de ses
antennes radio était endommagé et elle
rencontrait des problèmes informatiques
mais contrairement à son homologue
fictifs c'était un robot dépourvu
d'équipage humain et il y a eu une autre
grande différence
les lunes de jupiter se sont avérés bien
plus variées active et coloré que ce
qu'on avait imaginé dans les années 60
en août 2001 la sonde endommagé galileo
a frôlé la surface d'une des lunes puyoô
à moins de 200 km elle n'a pas repéré
des étendues de glace nu mais des
volcans en éruption
elle a même effleurer les vapeurs émises
par un de ces volcans
ces détecteurs on repérait des signe
indubitable de la présence de neige de
dioxyde de soufre dans le volcan à plus
de 800 millions de kilomètres les
scientifiques on respirait l'haleine
d'un autre monde et constater que la
réalité dépasse bien souvent la fiction
rené you ou la géologie et changeante à
l'échelle de la vie humaine
au cours d'une observation au cours des
quatre mois qui ont séparé voyageurs 1
et 2 le grand relief de sa surface ont
été modifiés si vous viviez là bas vous
n'auriez pas de bulletin météo mais un
bulletin géologique plus qu'aucun autre
monde
you a permis de se débarrasser de l'idée
naïve qui veut que les satellites des
planètes lointaines soit des boules de
glace mort n'est gelé
nous avions oublié la première règle de
l'immobilier c'est la situation qui
prime
rio est la plus proche des lunes de
jupiter
les subtils jeux de gravité en trio et
les autre monde tandis qu'elle tourne
autour de jupiter ont des conséquences
curieuse l'une d'elles c'est que la
température des eaux augmente sous
l'effet d'un phénomène appelé le
réchauffement de marée
cet effet de marée ce produit car les
satellites galiléens se trouvent sur des
orbites légèrement elliptique
il s'approche très près de jupiter puis
s'en éloigne beaucoup lors de sa
révolution de deux jours terrestres
autour de jupiter you subi l'attraction
gravitationnelle de la part de l'énorme
planète et des autres lunes
ces forces rivales pétrissent
l'intérieur de yo comme un boulanger une
boule de pâte à pain des siècles des
faits de marée ont réchauffé you au
point que son coeur est partiellement
fondu elle a le coeur à l'envers
cette lune de plus de 3600 km de
diamètre ne compte pas moins de 300
volcans dont plusieurs dizaines sont
actifs simultanément certains expulse de
la matière à quatre ou cinq cents
kilomètres d'altitude
les éruptions volcaniques recouvre sans
cesse la surface de you d'une couche
coloré de la v2 souffrent diverses
proportions
galileo l'a constaté sur presque toutes
les orbites certaine et découvertes de
galilée au sur les volcans de you inclus
l'existence dans certains endroits de
diverses éruption à haute température
elle dépasse tout ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui sur terre ce qui semble
indiquer un type de volcanisme
différents nous voyons peut-être
aujourd'hui sur liot un type de
volcanisme que la terre ne connaît plus
depuis trois milliards d'années
malgré cette activité volcanique
lione pas la lune dont les scientifiques
parlent le plus l'attraction vedette
c'est le deuxième satellite de jupiter
europe
même si elle est plus petite que notre
lune europe abrite un immense secret les
éléments fournis par les sons de
voyageurs et galileo laisse supposer
qu'un océan couvre toute sa surface
europe possède un coeur rocheuse qui
semble recouvert d'une couche dash deux
os bien plus profonde que nos océans
terrestres
cette eau était liquide ou solide
mystère europe et peut-être un aquarium
lunaire ou une boule de neige fondante
comme sa soeur io europe suit une orbite
elliptique et subit les effets de marée
comme elle est plus éloigné de jupiter
elle est moins malaxer mais les
scientifiques pensent néanmoins que cela
produit suffisamment de chaleur pour
faire fondre de la glace cette
hypothétique océans est recouvert d'une
couche de glace pratiquement dépourvu de
cratères galileo nous a transmis des
images incroyablement détaillés de sa
croûte fracturée et de ce qui ressemble
à de la neige fondue ou de l'eau qui
s'écoule le long de ces fissures
la principale caractéristique de la
surface de rock
ce sont des arêtes et les bandes de
terrain il y a des arts est relié par
des sillons ils sont très complexes et
sont là encore l'expression de processus
internes qui trahissent le déplacement
de matières en dessous de la croûte de
glace c'est de la glace élastique ou du
peut-il qui a rempli ses fractures
dans d'autres cas il peut s'agir d'eau à
l'état liquide qui a jailli à la surface
et qui a gelé il ya quelques zones où
les preuves d'un tel événement serait
assez bonnes dans un bon nombre de
régions d'europe
on voit que les plaques de glace peuvent
être assemblés comme les pièces d'un
puzzle on pense qu'un processus les a
séparés au départ et les a disposées
différemment les écarts créés ont été
remplis avec d'autres matières souvent
aux icebergs et à l'eau de mer quand on
regarde la surface de l'europe
y at il de la vie sur europe
rares sont les endroits dans le système
solaire qui dispose de plus d'un ou deux
des éléments nécessaires à l'apparition
et à la survie des formes de vie les
plus simples le seul endroit connu à
remplir ces conditions préalables c'est
la terre
la vie telle que nous la connaissons sur
terre a besoin de trois choses de l'eau
liquide ce qu'on appelle parfois des
éléments biogénique comme le carbone
n'avait qu'une connaissons en dépend
mais aussi de la zot du soufre du
phosphore et tout un tas d'autres
éléments
et puis il faut une source d'énergie et
la question à propos d'europe est la
suivante il a probablement un océan mais
y at il des éléments biogénique et
quelles sont les sources d'énergie car
on se trouve sous des kilomètres de
glace la photosynthèse est donc
impossible sur europe 1 la lumière ne
peut pas pénétrer cette glace impossible
donc de récolter la forme la plus
abondante d'énergie à savoir la lumière
du soleil
alors quelles sont donc les autres
sources
telles sont les questions qu'on se pose
en ce moment à propos d'europe
y at il des sources d'éléments
biogénique et d'énergie permettant la
vraie
les problèmes essentiels posées par ce
monde mystérieux apparaissent clairement
aux planétologues même si personne ne
connaît encore les réponses les
possibilités théoriques pourrait nous
surprendre
une des raisons qui poussent les
scientifiques envisagent l existence de
la vie sur des mondes éloignés comme
europe c'est la découverte sur terre
d'organismes appelait extrême au fil
comme leurs noms l'indiquent
ils vivent dans des environnements très
hostile comme les cheminées volcaniques
bouillonnante des fonds sous-marins la
lumière solaire n'arrive pas aussi loin
et l'oxygène est rare
pourtant ces créatures s'y épanouissent
l'idée qui vient naturellement avec
europe compte tenu de cet océan profonde
recouvert de glace c'est celle des
sources hydrothermales comme celles
qu'on trouve au fond des océans
terrestres qu'ils alimentent peut-être
la vie comme ils le font sur terre même
aujourd'hui dans l'environnement riche
en oxygène qui existe sur terre
certaines bactéries semble vivre sans
dépendre de ce gars ce type d'organisme
pourrait exister sur europe 1 il
pourrait y en avoir bien d'autres tout à
fait capable de se passer d'oxygène et
susceptibles de vivre par exemple près
des cheminées d'europe europe emmagasine
vraisemblablement les éléments
indispensables à la vie depuis sa
formation des comètes issus de la
ceinture de kuiper heurtent parfois
jupiter et ses lunes
les scientifiques pensent qu'au cours
des quatre milliards et demi d'années
écoulées
d'innombrables comètes ont percuté
europe lui fournissant ainsi d'hydrogène
le carbone l'azoté et les autres
éléments nécessaires à l'apparition
d'une éventuelle biosphère
mais avant de spéculer sur l'existence
de la vie nous devons savoir si cet
océan d'eau existe bien la mission
europa orbiteur qui doit décoller en
2008 devrait répondre à cette
interrogation
europa orbiteur est la prochaine grande
étape de l'exploration d'europe on va
envoyer un engin spatial qui au lieu de
passer à côté va se mettre en orbite les
impressionnantes images haute résolution
de galileo ne couvre que quelques pour
cent de la surface de la planète
nous voulons dresser la cartographie de
l'ensemble de la surface
le voyage prendra environ trois ans en
arrivant vers jupiter
la sonde se mettra en orbite autour de
la planète géante et de cellules pendant
17 mois elle va effectuer une série de
manoeuvres pour se positionner sur une
orbite circulaire autour d'europe ça
paraît tout simple ou presque
l'europe se trouve dans une zone de
radiations mortelles qui entourent
jupiter un astronaute bien protégé
mourait au bout de dix minutes à la
surface d'europe europa orbiteur se
trouvera à 10 m de l'équivalent du coeur
non protégé d'un réacteurs d'un gigawatt
c'est l'enfer une fois dans l'orbiteur
on sera dans cet incroyable champs de
radiations et le voyage ne durera qu'une
trentaine de jours la sonde va encaisser
du 2 mai garaad 2 millions de rade au
cours de sa révolution autour d'europe
pendant ce mois de travail il y aura
deux objectifs majeurs le premier sera
l'utilisation d'un altimètre laser qui
mesurera la distance exacte entre la
sonde et la surface de rang
cela permettra de savoir avec quelle
amplitude la glace s'élève et s'abaisse
au quotidien en d'autres termes on
mesurera les marais de rome si europe un
océan
quand elle est proche de jupiter les
marais créé par la planète science est
aussi devrait être plus haute de 30
mètres que lorsqu'elle est à l'autre
bout de son orbite
l'usl est loin plus les marées sont
faibles
ça tient au fait que les marais dépend
de la gravité et que la gravité
s'amenuisent avec l'éloignement tous les
trois jours et demi on verra donc le
flux de marée augmenté de 30 mètres puis
se réduire et augmenter à nouveau un
engin spatial en orbite devrait pouvoir
l'observer avec précision et nous
devrions voir europe se déformer en
temps réel sa résoudre à la question de
savoir s'il ya oui ou non un de ses
autres méthodes de vérification
un faisceau radars capables de pénétrer
la croûte de glace
on espère qu'un faisceau d'une certaine
longueur d'onde pourra y parvenir avant
de rebondir sur l'eau qui se trouverait
en dessous
si la classe n'est pas trop épaisse le
radar devrait mettre en évidence la
frontière entre la glace et l'eau
les scientifiques savent que cette
technique est viable puisqu'ils l'ont
testé sur terre nous avons déjà détecté
des lacs en dessous de la glace
l'antarctique
grâce aux radars à grandes longueurs
d'onde le lac vostok qui fait la taille
du lac ontario se cache sous des
kilomètres de glace il a été détecté à
l'état radars de ce type et ses contours
ont été cartographiés et on peut tenter
quelque chose d'identique sur eux
d'une certaine manière le chemin vers
europe commence au lac vostok des
ingénieurs ont profondément creusé la
glace et se sont arrêtés juste avant le
lac proprement dit
la prochaine étape s'annonce audacieuse
envoyé un appareil à travers ce qu'il
reste de croûte pour déployer un
sous-marin miniaturisés et stérile afin
de chercher des créatures vivantes dans
l'eau
les astronomes collaborent à ce projet
novateur il songe déjà à une mission
avancée pas avant plusieurs décennies
qui procéderait au même type
d'exploration sur europe
leur idée consiste à envoyer un appareil
qui sont fonds seraient dans la glace
avant de lancer un hydro bottes dans
l'océan d'europe
il serait équipé d'instruments capables
de détecter des formes de vie
la technologie nécessaire pour faire
fondre quelques kilomètres de glace ne
doit pas être sous-estimée surtout quand
il faudra opérer à 600 millions de
kilomètres ce sera une mission très
difficile comme envoyer un vaisseau sur
europe traverser la glace et fouiller
les eaux sans risquer d'y introduire des
microbes terrestre et de contaminer
l'océan
ce sont des questions fondamentales
auxquelles nous devons apporter des
réponses
car europe va s'avérer particulièrement
intéressantes comme cadre l'exploration
au cours de notre vie et de celle de nos
enfants nous voulons y aller pour savoir
si l'océan est accessible et si nous
pouvons envoyer des instruments pour y
chercher de la ville jour un de nos
enfants pilotera peut-être un sous marin
habité dans un océan extraterrestres
pour y trouver une forme de vie avec
2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
une équipe de talent a essayé d'imaginer
les lunes de jupiter
onze ans après la sortie du film la
sonde voyageurs de nous a montré à quoi
elle ressemblait vraiment et il s'est
avéré que la nature a une imagination
bien plus fertiles que les meilleurs
auteurs de science-fiction des geysers
plus froid que la glace des volcans plus
chaud que le feu des mystères dissimulés
par des nuages ou cachés sous la glace
toutes ces merveilles n'attendent que
nous l'année 2001 est désormais derrière
nous et nous nous tournons vers le
nouvel âge de l'exploration spatiale
les mondes des confins du système
solaire nous appelle un jour nous nous
posons sur heureux nos robots y
découvriront ilan océan emprisonné sous
la glace dont les eaux profondes et
sombre grouille de vie
nous raconterons t-il une histoire
encore plus étrange il est encore trop
tôt pour le dire
la véritable odyssée ne fait que
commencer